everyone is Charlie get rekt we finally
had a confrontation between thunder in
black lightning although technically she
hasn't gotten her thunder a comic book
name yet but the title of the episode
was book of thunder so it was all about
her character
just building towards a moment where
they all figure out what's going on so
with that in mind I will also try to
explain the big twist behind Gambian
Lady Eve because they have big history
together if you're finding me for the
first time I do DC videos every week be
sure to subscribe to get everything
so obviously spoiler warning if you
haven't seen the episode yet there are a
couple really big running plot lines and
then some stuff I think that they're
teeing up to pay off at the end of the
season like especially with lightning
and Khalil's character not to be
confused with black lightning remember
both of his daughters are thunder and
then lightning but because they're
spending all their time developing the
Thunder character right now it seems
like they'll save any big character
twist like manifestation of powers or
anything like that for lightning for the
very end of the season maybe they'll try
to tie that in with kahlil's arc because
it sounds like he's gonna be getting
powers too but the really big stuff
first I know it like everyone's mostly
talking about the gambi twist so gambi
goes to talk to lady eve they refer to
an agency that they belong to together
they can be retired from that makes it
sound like it was sort of an evil
version of Argos so biotech
assassination just any manner of ill
things that you could get your hands
into like Spectre in the James Bond
franchise lady Eve says she broke away
went free agent and gambi sort of went
on the DL by himself like he just fully
retired because of a mysterious incident
that probably has something to do with
the death a black lightnings father so
it's all connected remember and there's
also a drug on the street that they're
calling green light and there's also a
drug that Tobias whale is taking
something that he plans on giving to
Khalil so it's all connected it sounds
like the drugs go all the way back to
this shadow organization in Lady Eve and
the investigation into metahumans that
thunders grandfather was doing that got
him killed by Tobias whale the real key
here that connects everything is the
brain scans of the addicts that are
currently taking that green lightening
drug in black lightnings brain scans
himself they look the exact same he has
that line of dialogue where he says it's
almost like the powers are a drug in
gambi shrugs
you're just feeling endorphins like he's
trying to lead him off of the trail of
this shadow organization the agency that
he used to belong to that's behind the
drugs so it sounds like black lightnings
father found out that Black Lightning
was a metahuman they like started to
learn that he had weird abilities so he
started to investigate that that led him
onto the scent of the mystery agency
that Gambian lady belonged to that was
also doing research on metahumans in a
more sinister context they're trying to
replicate their powers they killed him
for it then eventually the agency was
successful they gave powers to Tobias
whale empowered him to take over the
hundred gang in this localized area of
Friedland so right now lady eve is the
big boss but there's an even bigger
agency that either disbanded or they
belong to so they're a bunch of other
really evil people that might be the TV
show's version of the cobra cult because
that's just the organization that lady e
belongs to in the comics remember during
defenders how the hand organization was
involved in all manner of ill [ __ ] like
they had their hands in the drug trade
there had their hand in Biosciences so
it sounds like this organization lady e
are trying to do the same thing albeit
with metahuman powers so that's where
khalil came in at the end of the episode
Tobias whale as you can see has super
strength
he doesn't age that's because of the
drug that lady Eve has been giving him
which was based on the stuff that black
lightnings father was killed for when he
started investigating it so I thought
that they were pretty clear on where
kahlil's character was going I'm
wondering if they're gonna tie the
emergence of Lightning's powers to an
event with his character at the end of
the season because Tobias is probably
just gonna use him to throw against
black lightning it just caused him some
more problems everybody kind of has
their own big boss to fight like it's
Tobias whale versus black lightning
thunder will get her own adversary to
take down and then lightning sort of has
her own story too although it really
doesn't seem like a whole lot is going
on with her right now I think that just
because they're saving that for the end
of the season
you will I promise you will no strength
be strength and believe me it's so much
fun so I feel like they did a good job
of explaining why gambi has been so
shady the last couple of episodes in
trying to hide Tobias whale from Black
Lightning because they had an
arrangement lady Eve is using Tobias
whale to sort of push the green light
drug that's all she really cares about
that's Tobias whales only function to
her just be someone to help her sell
more drugs make more money
Gabby doesn't want to have anything to
do with that but because he has all the
dirt on her what she's doing they made
the arrangement you leave black
Lightning's family alone but remember
nobody knows black lightnings secret
identity so when he says the Pierce
family is off-limits
she doesn't know anything about that
being connected to Black Lightning so
you have a couple different levels of
evil going on here you have the street
level stuff is going on which is people
pushing drugs to the kids on the streets
Black Lightning wants to clean that up
then you have the mid-level stuff going
on with Tobias whale and how Black
Lightning wants to get revenge for the
death of his father then you have this
upper tier level bad with Lady eve in
the shadow organizations that can be
belonged to like TV show Cobra cult
which has its hands in everything Hydra
style so Hydra is probably a really good
analogy because they're really just
trying to exploit metahumans for profit
create artificial metahumans and use
them to push more of this drug that's
based on the metahuman gene so it is no
coincidence that the drug that they're
pushing is called green light in the
name of the TV show is Black Lightning
that really didn't become super clear
until they put those two brain scans
right up next to each other on the
screen so if you have any other like
really big questions on the mythology or
like some of the big twists that they
reveal just write them below in the
comments but as you can see thunder is
still wearing the cosplay funny version
of her costume and they tease this
version before the season even started
so now that they've sort of come clean
with each other dad like oh he has to do
the explainer now yeah I'm black
lightning I've been doing this this
whole time gambi will probably help
construct a better version of the suit
for her that she'll wear later in the
season there are 13 episodes total
episode
seven is next week so we're at the
halfway point so it'll be interesting to
see how long they go before they
actually hit the streets together so
just let me know in the comments what
did you think of the episode I feel like
this is actually one of the better ones
like you can only go for so long with
two people in a family both being
metahumans without them finding out
about each other like I'm actually
really happy they didn't put this off
for the very end of the season because
now we can focus on lightening
developing powers but like I said I
don't think that that's gonna happen til
the last couple of episodes if not the
very last episode there's some new
Avengers that I'm working on probably a
couple Marvel videos so I'll try to get
that out as fast as possible arrow is
also back this week - in Roy is coming
back really soon so we'll say
congratulations to that latest flash
ring giveaway winner Coca Fanta please
private message me so I can get your
contact details click here for that
brand new flash trailer and click here
for my flash Easter eggs from last night
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight